the vaccine rollout is far from over
government immunization advisors have
told the nhs to be ready to give an
autumn booster to all over 50s health
and care workers
and those with underlying health
conditions a final decision will be
taken in september they back our plans
which are to roll it out from september
this year onwards and really to do what
it takes to keep the virus
at bay that's the objective and they're
saying that
you should obviously start with the most
vulnerable first and that's our plan
but the jcvi is still grappling with a
more immediate decision on whether to
include
all adolescents in the current rollout
many european countries are pressing
ahead analysis by sky news shows
20 have begun immunizing 12 to 15 year
olds or have plans to do so
the further six including the uk
currently inoculate
only children with underlying health
conditions and 11 have yet to make a
decision
there are two key reasons to give them a
jab
one is herd immunity to stop the virus
spreading
around 85 percent of the population
needs to be protected
either from vaccination or from having
had covid
but the vaccine is currently targeted at
adults
who only make up 79 percent of the
population so herd immunity is highly
unlikely without including
adolescents the second reason to
vaccinate them is to keep them in school
absences are rising with five percent of
people's now off because
someone in class had tested positive but
against
all that is the small risk of coveted
children
data shows there are lots of cases in
the under 15s
but very few are admitted to hospital
and they account for less than 0.03
percent of deaths
were the risks of the disease so low
doctors would want to be sure
vaccines are safe so all eyes are on the
united states which has given around
8 million doses to the under 18s more
than any other country
health officials are monitoring reports
of myocarditis
and inflammation of the heart muscle
it's very rare but it seems to be more
common
in those age 16 to 19 although almost
all have recovered well
it's a condition that can be caused by
other common viruses
but until it's clear whether the
vaccines are adding to the risk some
doctors will be cautious
about giving them at all to the young